in this short video we'll talk about the
process of oxidative deamination
in short this is a step in the
catabolism of amino acid that means
breakdown of the amino acid involves
this particular step
let us try to understand how
so this is the overview of amino acid
catabolism the detailed video is
provided in the eye button so let's say
you have four amino acid each of these
amino acid has amino groups and all of
that would ultimately form
glutamate so all of these amino acid can
be converted to glutamate then it can be
converted
to ammonia that means the amino group is
taken away from the amine amino acid
so this ammonia is toxic eventually it
can
go through the urea cycle and forms urea
so the first part is transamination the
second part that means from glutamate to
the production of ammonia this step is
known as deamination and lastly there is
urea cycle so relevant videos are
provided in the eye button but let us
look at the oxidative deamination in bit
more details so we understood that
glutamate will be converted to alpha
ketoglutarate and the ammonia will be
released and this is triggered by
glutamate dehydrogenase enzyme so
this particular reaction is taking place
in the liver principally
so ammonia is toxic that's why ammonia
would be
transformed into urea via the process of
urea cycle
this enzyme glutamate dehydrogenase is
situated
in the liver mitochondria
so if you look at the liver mitochondria
will find
these glutamate dehydrogenase enzyme is
pretty abundant
glutamate dehydrogenase is a homo
hexamedic allosteric enzyme and it can
it's a enzyme which is a bit different
from the others because it can bind to
nad and nadp simultaneously i mean it
can bind to both of them
so if we look at the monomeric structure
of glutamate dehydrogenase this this
somehow look like this particular
structure so it has a cofactor binding
domain and it has a substrate binding
domain and both of these domains are
connected by a hinge domain
now on substrate binding there are
conformational changes
so
the hinge helix is kind of
rotated in such a way that two
domains come closer to each other
closing the cliff here we see the
substrate binding and ultimately it
leads to closure of these two
domains and the pivot helix or this
hinge domain participate in this process
so now we look at
the allosteric activators and inhibitors
of these enzyme so the electro
allosteric activator involves nad nadp
and atp whereas the allosteric inhibitor
is the gtp
so the closed conformation is required
for catalyst
but the open conformation is required
for the association or dissociation of
substrate and product
so here is a close and the active
conformation in the closed state gtp
uh forms hydrogen bond with histidine 5
454 residue gdp binding actually favors
the closed state
whereas
the in open state
arginine 463
interacts with adp
so this is overall structural details of
this uh proteins and it's kind of like
not really relevant or necessary to
understand each details another enzyme
that is important for oxidative
deamination is monoamine oxidase
monoamine oxidase converts
neurotransmitters such as serotonin into
a corresponding aldehyde and ultimately
it free up ammonia so that means
degradation of
neurotransmitters such as epinephrine
and serotonin requires monoamine oxidase
a and monoamine acid oxidase b
so whenever the neurotransmitters are
reuptaken by the presynaptic cleft there
are enzymes such as monoamine oxidase a
which can break them down and thereby
reducing the concentration of serotonin
in the synaptic cleft
but
in case of depression
several medications are used as a
monoamine oxidase inhibitor and that
allows or prevents
the degradation of serotonin that means
serotonin would be present in a synaptic
cleft for longer duration and from that
point of view monoamine oxidase
inhibitors are really important to treat
depression so i hope this video was
short and it summarized the enzymatic
processes that
that kind of regulate the process of
oxidative deamination you can get some
notes regarding this topic in my
facebook channel link a link is provided
in the description as usual like share
and subscribe you can support my channel
in patreon you can follow me on an
academy which is india's biggest online
learning platform you can use my code ap
10 to get a 10 discount see you in the
next video all my social media links are
provided in description as well